[Music]
from the studio that Marvel let's play
with their toys comes the spider-man
fill and everyone wanted to see on
screen until they did hey Parker but
this time they can't even afford to put
spider-man in it
venom get ready for a gnarly sick type
movie you'll love as long as you're the
kind of person who says gnarly sick and
tie as the genre runs out of Silver Age
heroes to adapt and enters the extreme
90s era of leather jackets an attitude
for a film that would have been so much
better to a rated R but it made almost a
billion dollars so what do we know
witness Tom Hardy doing just the most
with a roll of Eddie Brock as he plays
the investigative reporter like a
crackhead squirrel Kiki you'll be
captivated by his New York accent I have
spent a significant amount of time with
one of these creatures of his
ever-changing man bracelets
and so many weird little noises you'll
wonder if they've been covering his
mouth for a reason watch everything
changed when he's infected by an evil
splooge from outer space who goes by
venom a member of a parasitic race it's
gonna conquer earth unless humanity can
somehow get its hands on a halfway
decent sound system together they'll
chomp their way through good and bad
guys alike prompting audiences
everywhere to wonder does any Brock know
what human flesh tastes like is he
technically a cannibal when venom bites
off a head his head II have to crap out
the skull later where these are Tom's
favorite parts that got cut out enjoy a
film of charm in action then stop
enjoying it while they bore you to death
with science talk one of the organisms
got out of containment lots and lots of
science talk you discovered a gene
therapy that literally doubles the life
expectancy of bang that's all these
hosts showing this hypercube metabolic
abnormalities that are making it hard
for your body to maintain homeostasis it
seems dubious adrenal endocrine their
protein running Diagnostics even fully
automated you can't pilot that craft all
alone directing the boredom is the not
so secretly evil Carlton Drake a man who
wants to destroy humanity in order to
save it we brought the planet to the
brink of extinction a plan shared by
this film's villain infinity wars
Mission Impossible fallouts and the
Predators and that's just in 2018 thrill
as Drake assumes his final form raisin
venom then tried to cheer on the hero as
the action concludes with two syrupy
blotches wrestling each other like a win
and visualizer with teeth if
whit's the llamas ass but Venom's not
just an action movie it's also a love
story as Eddie is torn between his love
of Michelle Williams terrible wig inside
and the special guy inside of him who's
ready to make the leap from I to we we
know it's not weird that I shipped sim
Brock the movie made a quarter billion
in China and this is how they advertised
it look ever since tumblr changed this
is all I got left
let me have this one epic voice Eloi key
yeah so enjoy a comic book film that
isn't bogged down by twenty other
episodes like the MCU or the grandiose
pretensions of the DC Universe sasame
amazing cuz sometimes it's fun to watch
a movie that's just a movie even though
it did so well Sony will probably use it
to kick start an entire cinematic
universe foreign past sony hard pass
unless you get flubber starring sad max
Pinky and the veins dan from beep and
and from venom meant a stir by the sea
feel on musk everyone goose the Rialto
Theatre the Rialto Theatre and that's
that's real to theater as well the
Rialto Theatre again what theaters that
Ellis the Rialto and Close Encounters of
the Third Kind going down the street
[Music]
if you're turds are thin or light enough
to roll in the wind please call your
gastroenterologist slow motion like baby
lotion I like to have my elbows too cold
Firefly is the opposite of waterfall
justice for blockbuster knock-knock let
the devil in